you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now well as
we talked about on Good Day Las Vegas
this morning there may not be astronauts
on board but there is a Snoopy doll go
back and take a look on our social media
live picture here from our camera on top
of the Bank of America building from the
Molasky family companies this is rainbow
in the 95. this is the flagpole that we
always show at the gas station down
there but you got the view of the strip
here plenty of blue sky as Sherry talks
about when we get North Wind that really
clears out the air now the wind advisory
is still in effect until six this
evening not for Las Vegas Colorado River
all the way down towards Laughlin parts
of San Bernardino and Northwestern
Arizona as well 56 degrees is the
official number for Las Vegas at read
but we always check in now at this time
yesterday we had some readings in the
upper 40s North winds still blowing
between 10 and 20 miles an hour some
temperatures up a degree or so from
yesterday and the Air Force Base you're
at 58 we check in elsewhere in Nevada
and Beyond one degree cooler right now
at Death Valley that was 24 hours ago
not quite down to 10 this morning up in
Ely or 36 right now same thing for Cedar
City over the proper 54. so temperatures
again really not changing a whole lot
here over the next seven or eight days
the wind is coming and going as our
waves of clouds we tried for 60
yesterday didn't quite get there I mean
the upper 50s that's still about 10
degrees below normal we'll try for 60
again low this morning at 42. also the
next system is cranking it up out here
there's going to be a lot more wind for
Friday and for Saturday waves of snow
moving across the Northern Plains and
into the nation's Ohio Valley your most
accurate eight-day forecast well there
we are sticking the temperatures about
the same 62 Friday down to the upper
50's and overnight lows in the 30s these
rounds of Gusty winds or something we're
just going to have to put up with off
and on over the next eight days Heather